hi everyone Thanks for uh joining me
here today I know it's been a long
conference but we'll get through it my
name is Neils benan I'm the chief ml
engineer at Union AI which is a AI
infrastructure company aimed at helping
organizations get value out of their
data through AI ml driven
applications but today I have my open
source hat on and I'm going to talk to
you a little bit about validating and
testing data frames in Python and R with
Pandera and
reticulate so back in 2012 I don't know
if you remember this article the uh
Harvard Business Review named data
science the sexiest job uh in the 21st
century but you know what isn't
sexy dealing with invalid data which may
seem like you know a losing battle when
incorrect or otherwise corrupted data
gets through your pipeline and what's
worse when others are relying on clean
data kind of Downstream from you and you
know it's if you find yourself having
that responsibility of creating clean
data sets for your team then this is a
very sucky
feeling
um so we all know that data validation
is important and we all know that it's
tedious and often thankless
right when we first learn any kind of Cs
Concepts we might have heard of garbage
in garbage
out data Centric machine learning is
more recent kind of buzz phrase and data
is code and all of these sayings in the
field point to data as one of the
primary resources or assets that we use
use to get value or to deliver
value
um but you might say I just want to
train my model or I just want to make
that pretty plot right and yeah that I I
was here once um in a previous job I had
to train a model looks very vanilla
right uh you clean data you split it in
train test splits you train a model you
evaluate the model in the train test
splits and at that time um I was using
some machine that wasn't as powerful as
I wanted it to be so it it took maybe 3
four days to train my
model and when it completed I discovered
oh no like my valuate model step failed
and digging into the code and finding
the bug it was because the test data
split that I was creating it was fairly
custom and and not
straightforward um was in correct and
all I had to do really was do some basic
assertions basic validations to uh just
test whether my data splits are were
correct and I would have avoided having
to wait and twiddle my thumbs
for okay um went to the orange website
for a bit sorry um yeah
so I hope that brief story inspires kind
of or justifies idea that data
validation is about understanding your
data and then capturing that
understanding as a schema so here's a
little sketch of what a schema might
look like right it's a just a Json blob
it says uh you have three columns and
they have these types so at its core a
schema is a docu uh is a artifact that
documents the shape and properties of
some data structure in this case we're
talking about data
frames and secondly schemas enforce that
shape and those properties
programmatically at runtime
perhaps so my job in this talk is not to
convince you that data science is the
most attractive part or you know of data
science but I do want to convince you
that data validation can be fun the way
you you do that is you reframe it as
unit tests for your data and just like
whenever you run your unit test you see
nice green check marks and you know
whichever like test Suite you use you'll
see some nice visual cue that all your
tests are
passing well if you Frame data
validation in this way you get that kind
of nice dopamine hit you know when you
see all these passing data set
validation
checks but you have to do a little extra
work to get to this fun part right and
there's like a very minor shift in the
way I would say one would work to to
incorporate data validation into their
mindset and their workflow so typically
you might Define a goal for your
analysis you might explore your data you
implement your data processing function
you kind of spot check the output of
that function and if it looks good you
just continue
right with the with the data Val
validation mindset you essentially it's
very similar to like unit testing or
test driven development but in in a very
similar way you when you explore your
data you capture that understanding in
terms of a schema and then you validate
your implementation of your data
cleaning function and when that passes
you continue your
analysis and so I hope I'm come getting
the point across that there's no
substitute for understanding your data
with your own eyes but once you get that
understanding it might seem like a
sefian task to create and then maintain
it as your data set shifts you know over
time as a real world as real world data
does so I built Pandera uh in Python to
lower that barrier to entry to create
your schema and then iterate it on it
over time and collaborate on a code
first artifact that will validate your
data and My Hope here is that
organizations that use it um at first it
was just me and my company at the time
would build a culture of data hygiene
and seeing the value of doing these
runtime
checks so as I said Pandera is a python
package it's a data testing U validation
and testing
tool and in this talk I'm going to show
you how you can use it with reticul
reticulate um which is an R python
bridge where you can interchange data um
functions and objects between the two
runtimes so so
what so the point here is that using
Pandera in your Python and R Stacks gets
you a single source of Truth for your
schemas data documentation as code for
you and your team to look at and runtime
data frame schema enforcers so you can
spend less time worrying about the
correctness of your data and more time
analyzing visualizing and modeling
them so in the rest of this talk I'm to
take you through a sort of mini data
validation Journey starting with
defining our goal so say we have a toy
data set here of transactions um
consisting of grocery store items and
their Associated prices and we want to
predict a price of items obviously there
would be a lot more columns here but
just for the sake of uh learning about
how Pender works we just have two right
here so we might start off exploring the
data we might print out the data data
types we might describe some of the
columns and plot out the distribution of
uh things we want to kind of grock
better with
visuals as you can see here we can start
building our understanding of what our
schema might look like right so item is
categorical represented as
strings it has three possible values
Apple orange
banana price is a float which is greater
or equal to
zero and NE columns can contain null
values so Pandera gives you a very
simple way to translate this
understanding into a
schema so let's look at our first
Pandera schema first we import the
package then we create a class and um
hopefully uh this is kind of clear
enough even if you're not super familiar
with python and classes but hopefully
you can kind of read this and see what's
going on where I'm subclassing data
frame model and that's how I kind of
Define my
schema and then I
Define some attributes in this class so
the item attribute is a string and in
this field function I'm basically adding
some more constraints that are not just
the data type so I'm saying item must be
it must be in this finite set of
values and similarly price is a float
that's greater or equal to
zero and finally both of these columns
are not
nullable um nullable equals false is
actually a default but I'm showing it
here just to be
explicit so now that we've defined our
schema we can just call schema.
validate and if the data you pass into
validate is valid then it simply returns
valid data so it applies a bunch of
those checks and if it's okay you get
your data and you can continue whatever
you're doing with that
data
however if the data is invalid so um in
this case we're defining invalid data
with a nan value in the price column and
then squash in as an item which has a
negative price which doesn't make sense
unless I'm paying you $1,000 for squash
if I try validating this invalid
data I get a schema error and if we
catch that schema error we can get the
failure cases that Pandera found in this
case Pandera is just going to kind of
serially go through all those
checks and raise the first one failure
case it
sees now that might not be good enough I
want to see what all the errors are so
um there's a lazy equals
true um option keyword argument you can
pass to the validate method and if you
do that Pender will raise a schema
errors exception and in this case the
failure cases are a lot more informative
so we can
see um that failure cases is itself a
data frame that contains information
about where the error happened what
column was the offending column which
check was associated with failure
and the exact failure case value that
caused this error um and then some bonus
metadata of like where the index was in
the data
frame so as you can see that this
package is really optimized for just
sort of like data science data Engineers
ml Engineers who are in the weeds in the
code and kind of want to roll their own
kind of reporting layer so this is how
Pandera reports um errors
you can easily integrate this with your
existing pipeline so assuming that you
have sort of functions defined for each
step of your pipeline this also works
with methods of course but in this case
we have a clean data function that
doesn't do anything it just Returns the
input um so this is the incorrect
implementation but in order to check the
output of this function to make sure it
uh conforms with the schema as we've
defined it we decorate the function with
this check types decorator of course
pass lazy equals
true and then we use type annotations to
say hey this is a data frame that
conforms with this schema and once
you've done this clean data is now a
data validator plus a function so every
time we call clean data we check all the
values of the output and in this case we
recover the failure cases we see we saw
earlier so you might say well squash is
an actual you know grocery item that
might make sense to have in this data
set so this is just a a slide to
communicate essentially that there's
this kind of constant updating process
where your schema is stateless it's all
described in your code and so as as your
data shifts over time you're going to
have to update that schema and you know
collaborate with your teammates make
changes to you know your source code
check that into git and you kind of
essentially have a track record of all
the changes that happened with your
schema um so in a more realistic setting
you may have thousands hundreds or
thousands of items so in the wild I've
kind of seen people use a pattern where
they kind of read in some metadata from
a Json file or something or they just
have it as a variable um like as a as a
constant variable able and then they
just plug that in
here Pender also provides some
additional nice things to uh refine your
schema and refine the validation routine
you wanted you want to apply to your
data and the way you do this is you
define a a config class underneath your
schema and if you say coer equals true
Pandera when you call validate it's
going to try to co all the broad
data types into the specified data
types this is a potentially
destructive lossy transformation so if
you you don't want to do it you know by
default it's
false um if you say ordered is true then
the raw data coming in coming in needs
to con be in the same exact order as you
specified in the schema this is
important to some
people strict allows you to say hey I
want to raise an error if there are like
random dangling columns that are just
like there in my data um that aren't
specified in my schema I can actually
say strict equals filter and it'll
remove those
columns I can say drop invalid rows
equals true and any checks that fail are
considered invalid rows and those are
dropped if that's what you want um and
then finally unique column names is true
just it does what it says um there are a
few more options but these just want to
give you a
sampling there also some built-in checks
so uh as you saw from that field
function that's attached to this the
column attributes we can Define some
other constraints like the values must
Encompass all of the the finite um the
finite set so unlike is in which a valid
column would just have a column with all
A's a valid a valid column in this case
would be a column that has to contain at
least one of each of those
um you can also do string pattern
matching there are a few other built-in
methods here um like in range checks
some very basic ones right uh greater
equal to less than or equal to things
like
this however if your uh the built-in
checks don't fulfill your use case
Pandera just makes it super easy to
create custom checks and so you do this
by defining methods that you decorate
with um panda. check and in this case
this will just make sure column 1 and
two's means are within some range so as
long as this method outputs a Boolean a
Boolean series um Pender will know what
to do with
it you can also do data frame level
checks by saying at data frame check and
you essentially have access to the
entire data data frame and here you can
do whatever you want as long as you uh
stick with that kind of constraint of um
outputting a a Boolean Boolean series or
data frame
series um the last part I'll show you
before going into R is regex column
matching so say you have a data frame
with a thousand columns and they all
kind of have similar semantics and but
they're kind of named in a similar way
you can specify an attribute that has an
alias essentially becomes a regular
expression when you say r x is true same
goes with these at check um column level
checks and essentially you will apply
the validation to any column that
matches that regular
expression um so just a brief comment
before going to reticulate is you know
this quo document is validated by
Pandera so minor Meta Meta comment there
all the code you see here here has been
validated so that's
awesome
so just to address the elephant in the
room uh there are are packages that do
data validation like Point Blank and
validate why would you want to do this
Frankenstein's thing with python um in
the first
place uh and to be honest the real
answer is you know because we can but to
give you a few reasons that may make
sense you know maybe you're already
using Pandera and you want to reuse
those uh schemas in an R
runtime uh maybe the Pandera programming
model just fits better in your brain I
don't know uh or you just want R and
python to get along and you just want to
give it a
try but with that let me import a few
things uh in my toolkit to get started
here so using d r Knitter and reticulate
and I'm using a cond EnV where I have
all of my dependencies
installed
and it just works right uh I Define a
data frame in R and I use the pi entry
point
here and it returns a valid
data um just a warning this hasn't been
comprehensively tested in all the data
types so don't want to get you too
excited um you can catch python
exceptions um sorry that's a typo it
should be R exceptions but yes the
python in the r um reticulate runtime so
this is essentially the equivalent of
the tri catch thing in
Python and we get the same failure
cases and the last thing I just want to
show you here is synthesizing test data
with Pandera so if you call schema.
example or dollar sign example I can
create valid data under the constraints
of my schema and sort of running low on
time but this is super useful for unit
testing so
um yeah maybe I can just show you this
test process uh test that will create
some mock data try to process some data
and um tell you if your tests have
failed or not and so in the happy path
they
pass but if there's a bug in the data
like a column that is has a typo the
test will fail
and data validation is not only about
testing the actual data but also the
functions that produce
them um so you can get
started you know installing Pandera um
but I do want to say last that you know
I think our data wants to be validated
so we should you know help them along
with that thank
[Applause]
you Neils you have a lot of questions
I'm sure people are going to be super
excited to talk to you um right outside
uh we'll do one very quick one is
Pandera configured to only work with
pandas data frames or does it work with
a variety of classes like poers yeah
polers is on the road map so that's
there's an issue for this it currently
supports
modin P spark so it's obviously python
Focus um dask data frames geopandas data
frames um with polers on the way and
then we kind of have our eyes set on x
aray and Ibis for so Ibis would be for
uh in database validation a very cool
thank you so much this was great thank
[Applause]
you